so you've already binge the mandalorian
now what if you're still wondering
whether or not to stick by the house of
mouse we've got you covered
here's your comprehensive rundown of all
the exciting original shows and movies
being produced exclusively for Disney
Plus in 2020 this is the big one
the mandalorian and baby yota stormed
the Internet when Disney Plus launched
in November of 2019 and the show seemed
to hit that sweet spot of mainstream
success and obsessive fandom that made
it a must watch the second season of the
show was obvious what's surprising is
how quickly we'll be able to sit down
and watch it as soon as the first season
finale debuted in December showrunner
Jon Favreau revealed that the second
season of the mandalorian is slated to
arrive in fall 2020 the show debuted on
November 12 2019 so the follow up
arriving a year later seems like a
pretty good bet there were quite a few
cliffhangers left over at the end the
Mandalorians first season we and the
characters don't know much real
information about baby Yoda and all
signs point to the second season
focusing on the search for the child's
home there's also the threat of mop
Gideon and his dark saber to deal with
one of the two original MCU shows coming
to Disney Plus in 2021 division looks to
be a bit of a strange one
the series focuses on Wanda Maximoff aka
Scarlet Witch and her late Android lover
vision who up until now was maybe the
deadest character in the entire MCU as
for how he's back or what they'll be up
to that's anyone's guess so far the
imagery we've seen from Wanda vision
evokes a particularly strange Leave It
to Beaver vibe Paul Bettany reportedly
told an audience at the d23 Expo that
the show would have old school sitcom
vibes with some serious darkness hidden
just below the surface some familiar
faces from the MCU will appear along the
way including Darcy Lewis Jimmy woo and
an all grown-up Monica Rambeau now
played by Tiana Paris we're intrigued to
see what will bring them all together
considering where the MCU appears to be
headed with some of its post infinity
saga releases it's been theorized that
Wanda vision will serve as a way to
introduce supernatural and poorer
elements into the greater MCU guardians
of the galaxy did something similar with
cosmic concepts on its original release
and Doctor Strange opened the door for
mysticism to find its way into the
franchise it'll be interesting to see
what types of risks Marvel and Disney
take with Wanda's really
depending powers post endgame few is the
second MCU show hitting Disney Plus this
year is falcon in the Winter Soldier
we've got a few details on this one but
the showrunners have generally played it
pretty close to the chest anthony mackie
and sebastian stan will be reprising
their title roles and a lot of the other
cast has been revealed as well daniel
bruhl is returning as captain america
civil wars helmet Zima Emily VanCamp
will reprise her role as Sharon Carter
Wyatt Russell meanwhile joins the cast
as John Walker aka u.s. agent Falcon in
the Winter Soldier is slated to consist
of six episodes that will release weekly
rather than all at once a strategy
Disney Plus seems to be favoring for all
of its original series with director
Carey schoo Glenn at the helm for every
episode the show looks to follow in the
vein of the Captain America films
playing like a spy thriller it will
focus on Sam Wilson adapting to his role
as the new Captain America following the
events of Avengers endgame Star Wars the
Clone Wars set during the time between
attack of the clones and Revenge of the
Sith originally debuted in 2008 as a
feature film that served as a pilot for
the animated series the show then ran
for five seasons on Cartoon Network
before being cancelled with 13 left over
episodes eventually hitting Netflix as a
makeshift six season but there are still
scripts left unproduced and plot threads
left dangling fans kept hope alive and
they're campaigning was finally rewarded
when a definitive seventh and final
season was announced for Disney plus a
trailer released in January 2020 teased
the revivals thrilling return to the
storylines fans have been waiting to see
concluded for years the romance of
Anakin and Padme the moral struggle of
the clone soldiers and a climactic
showdown between ahsoka tano and Darth
Maul it's a miracle revival that fans
have been waiting for the wait finally
ends on February 21st The Muppets are
coming to Disney Plus in 2020 but not in
the format you might expect
Muppets now will feature celebrity
guests then is being touted as an
unscripted series but there aren't a ton
of details available outside of that the
promise of celebrity guests suggests
that the project could resemble the
original Muppet Show variety series from
the 1970s but will have to wait for more
details to learn more The Muppets last
had a show on ABC in 2015 following a
pair of feature films in 2011 and to
14 these iterations were largely
dedicated to playing on the nostalgia of
adults who grew up with the characters
time will tell that Muppets now
represents a fresh retooling for a
streaming audience but regardless it
will be a welcome return to the
spotlight Phineas and Ferb a cartoon
series that ran from 2007 through 2015
is the story of two brothers who are
constantly inventing extraordinary ways
to pass time during their summer
vacation their sister Candace is always
trying to get them in trouble and their
pet platypus moonlights as a James
bond-esque spy constantly thwarting the
villainous plans of dr. Doofenshmirtz
pretty standard stuff the original
creators are returning for a feature
film called the Phineas and Ferb movie
Candace against the universe according
to Disney's official announcement at d23
in 2019 the plot will feature the two
brothers travelling across the galaxy to
rescue their sister the Phineas and Ferb
movie Candace against the universe will
reportedly release in the summer of 2020
Oh an official date has yet to be
announced
well there have been some behind the
scenes shake ups during production and
as far as we know we can still expect a
full season of the Lizzie McGuire
reboots in 2020 Hilary Duff is confirmed
to return in the title role with much of
her supporting cast expected to be on
board as well the new Lizzie McGuire was
set to kick off with Lizzie's 30th
birthday in new york city where she
would be seen working as an interior
design apprentice however variety
reports that show creator terry Minsky
parted ways with the reboot after only
two episodes were filmed according to a
Disney spokesperson after filming two
episodes we concluded that we need to
move in a different creative direction
and are putting a new lens on the show
the show is supposed to release this
year and possibly still will we just
don't have further details yet get some
more Pixar in your life with monsters at
work this series is a direct sequel to
monsters inc picking up 6 months after
the 2001 film it will introduce a new
character
Tyler tusks men who graduates as the top
scarer in his college class he comes to
work at monsters Inc on the day the
company switches over from scares to
laughter leaving him unsure how to move
forward much of the monsters movies
all-star cast including John Goodman and
Billy Crystal will reunite for the
series with Tyler being played by Ben
Feldman known for his work on Mad Men
Silicon Valley and more I just want to
be a part of this place I think it's on
the way up
there's no official release date yet for
monsters at work but Disney has
announced that we can expect it this
year
you might remember these two cartoon
Chipmunks from the 1989-90 Rescue
Rangers cartoon but chippendale have
been around much longer than that they
originally appeared as troublemakers in
classic Disney animated shorts starting
in the 1940s frequently antagonizing
Donald Duck or Pluto Disney Plus s plans
for the chipmunk duo and is rebooting
Chip and Dale and that classic cartoon
philosophy the new cartoon will be
comprised of 39 short episodes of about
7 minutes each
it will feature mostly situational non
verbal comedy focusing on the life of
the two characters surviving in the big
city
there's no set release date yet but we
do know Chippendale is come in at some
point in 2020 until then go watch the
1952 short Pluto's Christmas tree on
Disney Plus to see what these Chipmunks
are all about
remember legends of the Hidden Temple
and guts if you've got fond memories of
those kid competition shows you might
want to keep your eyes peeled for Star
Wars Jedi Temple challenge it's a
live-action skills-based gameshow set in
the Star Wars universe it's also set to
be hosted by Ahmed best to portray Jar
Jar Binks in the prequel trilogy Jedi
Temple challenge will test contestants
skills in three different settings a
forest planet a star cruiser and a Jedi
Temple according to Dan Silver vice
president of Disney original unscripted
contents Star Wars Jedi Temple challenge
brings together the best of Star Wars
competitive spirits harrowing obstacles
and a hero's triumph over challenges in
a totally new format for the franchise
it's a bit of an odd one but Star Wars
Jedi Temple challenge could be pretty
fun it's hard to tell until the release
gets closer and as of now there's no
concrete release date other than
sometime in 2020 based on Jerry
Spinelli's novel of the same name about
nonconformity and romance in highschool
star girl is set to arrive on Disney
Plus on march 13th 2020 it's the story
of high schooler Leo who's all struck by
a new student susan star girl caraway
star girl is unique interesting and
refuses to conform to teen social norms
causing much of the school to turn
against her leo however falls in love
with her and star girl center is the
acting debut of grace van der Waal a 15
year old singer/songwriter who won
America's Got Talent in 2016
vander waal had massive charisma and
stage presence during her run on
America's Got Talent so it'll be fun
seeing her in an acting role as an added
bonus she'll be displaying her singing
and ukulele skills as well
the runaway popularity of cooking
competition shows in recent years has
been hard to miss so it's no surprise
that Disney Plus has one on the way in
2020 VR chef will feature two families
competing each week to create Disney
themed dishes that fit in the confines
of that week's challenge with the
winning team's final dish being turned
into a treat that will actually be
served at Walt Disney World we invite
you to relax let us put up a chair as
the dining room proudly presents your
dinner PR chef is hosted by Angela
Kinsey who is probably best known for
playing Angela on the US version of The
Office Kinsey now hosts a Youtube
cooking show with her husband baking
with Josh and Ange further details about
be our chef including an exact premiere
date are yet to be announced but we
can't expect the competition to arrive
on Disney Plus at some point this year
no this has nothing to do with Johnny
Five instead short circuit sounds like
it could be a really fun way to discover
new talent in the animation world short
circuit is a short film project that
Disney began back in 2016 purportedly
allowing anyone at Walt Disney Animation
Studios the chance to pitch their own
ideas for potential production with the
full support of the studio the project
opens the door for potentially risky
unique or offbeat stories that might not
otherwise have been told 14 different
short films will debut and short
circuits premiere on Disney Plus at the
end of January
Disney has showed off a few of these
films at various Expos and trade shows
like just the thoughts exchange students
and Jinghua it looks like each film will
vary wildly in tone and animation style
and it might be fun to see some
undiscovered talent at Disney work their
magic if you saw Toy Story 4 and were
confused about how Bo Peep wound up
where she did lamp life has got you
covered the story was originally
conceived as a flashback that would
appear in the film but it was eventually
cut for time and pacing issues instead
it's been reworked into the short film
lamp life premiering on Disney Plus at
the end of January lamp life will reveal
how Bo Peep made the journey from Andy's
family to second-chance antiques it will
feature a few familiar voices from the
Toy Story films including Annie Potts as
Bo Peep Emily Davis as billy goat gruff
and al
Mackey is giggle mcdhh impuls lamp life
is directed by Valerie Lapointe who has
directed a few other Pixar short films
and was a writer on Toy Story 4 choosing
to release lamp life as its own short
film instead of an extra alongside Toy
Story 4 seems to indicate that it's been
fleshed out quite a bit
Pixar fans will definitely want to check
it out based on the Timmy failure book
series by Stephen past Asst timmy
failure mistakes were made is a film
about a young boy who runs a detective
agency in Portland Oregon
one day Timmy's failure Mobile segue his
mother won in a contest is stolen and
Timmy sets out to crack the case with
his partner by the way Timmy's partner
is an imaginary 1500 pound polar bear
judging from the trailer Timmy failure
mistakes were made looks like a fun
cross between encyclopedia brown and
Calvin and Hobbes considering the source
material the film could launch a whole
family-friendly franchise if it's
successful we'll find out how it goes
and hopefully who took the segue when it
hits Disney Plus On February 7 2020
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]